What are these idols that you
are all in duty too, in
constant dutifulness to. Their
allegiance was to these idols
that they worshiped. So,
Ibrahim is asking them this
question. From this, some of
the scholars have taken that
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam was one of
the messengers that was given
the message and given
revelation while he was in his
youth. Usually, prophets and
messengers are sent at the age
of forty. This is usually when
revelation begins. As if
mentioned but there are to
this. Such as Yahia. Yahia is
an exception to this.
That revelation and prophethood
was given to Yahia while he was
a young boy. Likewise, Asa
Alaihi Salam, he spoke in his
cradle. And he spoke with words
that articulate that he is a
messenger of Allah. He said,
Allah has given me revelation.
He has given me the book to
deliver. Likewise, is the
situation with Ibrahim Alaihi
Salam. Ibrahim Alaihi Salam, he
was he was given revelation and
he was appointed as a prophet
in his young age, in his youth.
Before the age of forty, while
he was still with his people,
while he was still amongst his
people, as a young man. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala describes
Ibrahim during this. Referring
to him a feta. A feta is a
young man in the Arabic
language. A young, strong boy
They said, they replied, we
found our fathers upon the
worship of these idols. That is
their evidence. Their evidence
is people who came before us,
our forefathers, they worshiped
these idols. So, we worship
them too. That's the extent of
their of their argument. This
is a terrible argument. A
terrible argument to have when
you meet Allah is to say
everybody else was doing it.
This is a very bad argument.
This is neither logical. Nor
does it have any connection to
the revelations of Allah and
the authority of the
revelations of Allah. On the
day of resurrection, a person's
argument will be bolstered and
based on reason or revelation.
That is it as for everybody
else was doing it, this is a
very terrible argument and an
argument that will not be
successful in the courts of
Allah. Ibrahim Alaihi Salam
said to his people, indeed,
certainly, you and your
forefathers were in clear
error. Your error is very
clear. from somebody on the
outside looking in can very
clearly see the error of your
ways. But what kept them even
though their errors were clear?
What kept them upon this path
of misguidance? What kept them
upon this path of misguidance
is their blind allegiance to
their forefathers. Their blind
allegiance to culture. They're
allegiance to to their ways.
Our forefathers did this. We've
always done this. Everyone who
came before us. our founding
fathers, they did this so we do
it. And this kind of psychology
will cause a person to reject
the truth and accept falsehood.
And fight against the truth
even if it is the messenger of
Allah. And except falsehood
even if that means accepting
the enemies of Allah. This
blind allegiance is displaced
and is impermissible for a
person to have. A person cannot
have blind allegiance. Rather a
person must always question
authority. Think for
themselves. Based on what they
learn from the Quran and the
Sunnah. Based on what they know
from Allah. Based on what they
know from reason. Blin
allegiance is very dangerous
They said to him in response,
are you serious or are you
joking about this matter? They
couldn't believe that anyone
would question the validity of
the ways of their forefathers.
Their founding fathers, they
couldn't believe that. Are you
joking or are you serious? He
said, rather your lord, the one
who is only rightfully
worshiped. is the king and
possessor of the heavens and
the earth, the one who has
created them and I hereby
testify to such. Meaning, I
testify before Allah, my
testimony is that, the only one
worthy of worship is Allah, the
creator of the heavens and the
earth, without any partners. He
then said to himself in
plotting against these idols by
Allah, indeed, I will come to
destroy these idols after you,
all are not, when you all are
not looking, when you're not
paying attention, I will.
Destroy these idols. He said
this to himself, in himself.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
tells us what exactly happened.
Ibrahim then proceeded to break
these idols apart He destroyed
them with a pick. He broke them
apart except for the biggest
idol of them all. It said that
he took this acts and he placed
it next to the big idol. So, we
have many many idols. The
number of idols is a difference
of opinion amongst the
scholars. Some mention
seventy-two idols. Whatever it
was. There's a number of idols.
There are different shapes and
there are different sizes. It
said that Ibrahim Alaihi Salam
took the axe, broke all of
idols and then he placed the
axe next to the biggest idol
and he left it there When they
came and discovered their idols
and tatters, they asked, who
has done this to our idols, to
our gods? Indeed, this person,
has transgressed. They then
started to kind of investigate
and said, we only heard one
young boy, mentioning our idols
and a negative light. Asking
about them, why do we worship
them, etcetera? This is a this
young boy's name is Ibrahim.
So
they agreed to bring Ibrahim
publicly. For everyone to see
and question him about these
idols. When they brought
Ibrahim, they asked him, did
you do this to our idols? Did
you destroy them? Did you break
them up?
He said,
it appears that the
biggest one did this because he
left the axe there with the
biggest idol. And so when he
saw the idols and he was
brought there, he said, it
looks the biggest one did
it. The axe, the murder weapon
is still in his hand. It's
still there with him.
and so, they referred back to
themselves, meaning in
themselves. When he said this,
immediately, the truth was
undeniable. So, they said,
we're wrong for worshiping
these idols. That's a good
point. That's an irrefutable
point. That's an impregnable
argument This is pure logic.
It's not possible for these
idols to hurt each other. Let
alone anything else. Neither
can these idols defend
themselves.
a Shaitan, an ego, an arrogance
came back So, the truth when it
first arrives, a person cannot
deny it but then, over time,
they can push that truth back,
compartmentalize it, and start
to
defend falsehood They said
you know very well that these
idols cannot speak. You're
asking us. You're telling us we
should ask the idols. But you
know very well just as well as
we do that these idols are
mute. They don't speak.
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam then said,
if that is the case, why then
do you worship Other than
Allah, that which cannot
benefit you in any way nor can
it harm you. If these things
can't even speak for
themselves, can't even defend
themselves. Can't even
physically do things that we
ourselves are superior to them
in. why then, would you worship
these things?
He said, I reject and I am
hereby disgusted and I denounce
that which you worship other
than Allah Will you not all
come to reason? It's clear that
these things, they cannot
worship, they cannot defend
themselves, they cannot
you. Why are you worshiping
them? It is only Allah that has
these attributes which make him
worthy of the worship of his
creation. What was their
response? They had no argument.
Their response was, burn him a
li
burn him at the stake and this
is the response of the
disbelievers, those enemies of
the prophets and messengers
when they're unable to argue
anymore, it turns violent. And
when violence starts to be
their agenda against the
messengers of Allah, that is
when Allah begins their descent
into his punishment. They begin
their own destruction by
scheming violence against their
messenger. The messenger might
be amongst them, he might call
them to Islam, and they may
remain in that standoff for
many years. But when they start
to plot, an assassination, or
they start to plot, to murder,
their profit, their messenger,
this is when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Begins the process of
their
destruction and Allah has
promised his messengers that he
would that he would
Deliver them And he would give
them victory. And so the
messengers, they are protected
by Allah. In order to deliver
their messages in in the full.
[Arabic recitation]